hi good morning my name is Mike Jewett
and I'm a professor in chemical and
biological engineering at Northwestern
University and very excited to be here
today to talk to you about some of the
work that we're doing in the context of
establishing cell free biology for the
production of therapeutics materials and
chemicals of course before I get started
I'd like to thank my team I think just
as in all research the people that
really do the work and really move the
science forward and we've also been very
fortunate to be funded by a variety of
organizations and some of the work I'll
be talking about today has been funded
in particular by the Office of Naval
Research DARPA and the Army Research
Office so very excited to have the
support from those different
organizations really what motivates me
as a scientist is the idea that over the
next century food energy chemicals and
materials really I believe we're going
to be transformed by our ability to
engineer biological systems whether that
being using a micro organism to for
example produce pharmaceuticals or or
rubber for your tires or even spiders
though because as next-generation
materials and while I think we can all
agree and certainly in the scientific
community about the importance of using
biological systems to produce molecules
as a powerful technology the promise
transformation is really moving slower
than one desire so here's just a
snapshot of a variety of small molecule
chemicals that have been produced
heterologous ly over the last few years
at least at the commercial scale so one
three propane dial artemisinin varna
seen and and and one of the things that
really these systems have in common is
that in order to engineer a
microorganism to produce a small
molecule it's really costly and slow so
you can see the time to market there in
particular in the in the decades of time
here 15 years or 13 years and what's
what's more noted is is R&D years here
the time in which it takes these
processes to be developed during the
hundreds of person years of time so if I
were to basically establish that for my
own lab that that basically starts to
run into the hundreds of PhD students
if you're thinking about 500 person
years and so while engineering biology
could be very useful certainly
contributing to the National bio economy
and a variety of other formidable
challenges that our society is facing
we'd like to step back and ask some
questions about why is engineering
biological systems so hard I think that
there are many reasons and certainly
were you know we're not the first to
think of these but there a variety of
possible reasons so one of these is just
that we have an incomplete knowledge of
how biological systems work so if I'd
like to take a microorganism and and and
feed it a substrate and convert that
into a valuable product I might not
necessarily understand all of the
metabolic networks that go on inside of
the cell or the transcription factor
regulation networks that I need to
control in order to to channel the
ability of the organism to produce a
product of interest for me secondly
cells have a lot of unforeseen
interferences there's there's unwieldy
complexity and oftentimes these are
these are major challenges one of the
things my lab really centers on is is
that it's actually very difficult to
balance intracellular fluxes to
optimally satisfy active synthetic
pathways while the machinery of the cell
is functioning to maintain reproductive
viability so put another way engineering
living organisms is really hampered by
our ability to manage both the cellular
objectives so basically evolutionary and
adaptation objectives that a cell might
have but in addition the engineers
process objectives so so basically the
idea that I would like to be able to to
synthesize a micro a product and this
tug-of-war really it is fundamental in
our challenge to be able to use micro
organisms and cellular factors and so so
what comes to bear is that new tools are
needed to harness the powerful and
synthetic functional capabilities of
biological systems and I think that
there are many exciting opportunities
particularly leveraging our newfound
ability to read write and edit DNA and
and and there within this context of
what my lab really focuses on is
something called cell free systems and
really these types of systems open the
aperture of the traditional engineering
biotechnology so for example what you're
able to do is take a microorganism which
is shown here
you actually lice that microorganism and
you harness the intracellular components
of that microorganism essentially as a
catalyst that enable you to convert raw
materials into a variety of bio-based
products and and really what this
affords you the ability to do for the
first time is to truly decouple catalyst
synthesis from catalyst utilization and
I think we're really excited about kind
of this decoupling because because this
actually begins to separate now this
tug-of-war that I mentioned is a
fundamental challenge on the previous
slide and so this is really a new
approach is the merging approach I'd
like to talk to you about some of the
advantages and some of the new and
exciting opportunities that are really
coming from from this approach so in
particular cell free biology so this
idea that we can activate complex
biological processes without the cell so
basically what you've done is you've
taken a cell you've ripped off the cell
wall and you collect the gun think about
it as kind of collecting the guts of the
cell
we're opening the hood and now you can
take that and you can you can direct
that to produce a product of interest
the advantages of this are multifold so
first of all you actually separate
catalyst synthesis from growth and so
this is important because now all of a
sudden we get to decouple the
evolutionary objectives of the cell and
those process connectors of the engineer
you lack structural boundaries and this
is actually subtle but remarkably
important it allows you for the first
time to really have direct access to the
reaction conditions that exist inside of
the cell and this is this is important
because now you can not only do things
that wouldn't be possible in a living
organism but you can additionally so for
example you can sample the system of
interest directly without being behind
the barrier of a cell wall you can also
have non-natural components and I think
this is there's some very exciting
opportunities there the other thing is
that we lack cell viability constraints
so this allows you to perhaps produce
molecules would otherwise be toxic to a
cell it allows you to direct all the
resources of the substrate that you're
feeding that you would like to be
molecularly transformed into a useful
product towards the exclusive production
product again we no longer have to also
support life of thyself and this really
begins to offer a new paradigm of
logistics and on-demand bio
manufacturing and so what I'd like to
talk with you about kind of over the
remaining 15 to 20 minutes of my are
some exciting new avenues in this idea
of bio manufacturing without walls so
the idea that you can utilize cellular
lysate source lu extracts to produce
small molecules protein therapeutics and
and even materials on demand so my lab
actually works in three major areas so
the first area is in cell free protein
synthesis so the idea is we use a little
crude lysate of a cell to produce
proteins and we'll talk about that for
producing therapeutics and materials we
also are developing newfound abilities
to basically create synthetic ribosomes
so the ribosome is the molecular machine
of the cell that produces proteins and
we'll talk about that and although we're
not going to talk about it today my lab
is also working in the field with cell
for metabolic engineering or pathway
debugging in bio synthesis of chemicals
and materials so let's talk about cell
free protein synthesis this is actually
a very historic field so it was used
initially in the 60s to discover the
genetic code by Nuremberg of a thigh and
and and certainly others more recently
in order to carry out cell free protein
synthesis what this means is basically I
take the crude lysate of a cell and and
direct proteins to be synthesized so I
take in this case this is meant to
represent the inside of the cell that
contains all the necessary factors for
protein synthesis so aminoacyl trna
synthetases tRNAs elongation factors
initiation factors and ribosomes and
basically we grow up cells and we
harvest those in mid exponential phase
we lyse those cells and we prepare a
crude extract we then basically take
that extract we feed it substrates and
salts so in this case the substrates and
salts are necessary both for the product
so substrates are energy and ATP and
such as ATP and amino acids are needed
for producing proteins and the salts are
necessary to create the right
physiological environment we have a DNA
template shown and kind of here and that
Durex the synthesis of a particular
protein and so this is a combined
transcription and translation system
that exists inside of a test tube so
we've basically taken the fundamental
molecular machinery of life and we put
it in a test tube but we're learning how
to activate and control that really
there's been a driving force and several
that have been driving the development
of cell-free protein synthesis
technologies so first of all these
technologies are very efficient because
they allow you to exclusively produce a
single product they can be the simple
adaptable and controllable they allow
you in particular to produce many many
proteins in large arrays and they also
allow for rapid product product and
process development timelines so if you
try to produce a protein for example
inside of a cell that often takes you
know at the current technologies on the
order of one to two weeks depending on
how fast this this this goes certainly
in one of my graduate students hands
whereas a cell-free translation system
once you have the plasmid or the DNA
template of interest it really takes out
the order of hours two days and really
advances in the last decade of a
possible cost-effective high yielding
bacterial cell free translation so this
is just an image which shows a protein
being produced in this case it's
chloramphenicol acetyl transferase on
the y axis on the x axis is time in
hours and so basically what we do is we
add a cell-free protein synthesis
reaction to the bottom of an Eppendorf
tube and then we watch the protein being
synthesized with time and so what you
observe here for example is the amount
of active protein being synthesized for
time in the system so we producing up to
about 700 micrograms per milliliter
really when you look even commercially
producing protein on about the order of
gram per liter quantities is is really
significant and and importantly
basically as the last decade we've been
able to produce protein in particular
here we're showing about a tenfold
improvement over an initial state of the
art it's really opened the way to new
applications so if you look over the
last decade you can see protein yield
per time is basically increasing where
we're now producing on the order of
multiple grams per liter it makes test
tube reactions the synthesis rate has
been increasing with time there
batch reaction duration has been
increasing with time and all of these
combined with lowering of the overall
economics so the cost associated system
I mean even enabled microscale to
manufacturing scale synthesis of these
systems on the order of 100 liters so
there's really a dawn of a new era of
salford protein synthesis systems so you
can see here 1996 the micro liter scale
and really we learned how to produce
protein very cost-effectively starting
in about 2008 by activating respiration
and glycolysis to to drive cell free
protein synthesis and these reactions
are now being run at the hundred metre
scale which is just remarkable
when you think about the development
that's happened over the last 10 to 15
years and so people are now trying to
tap into that just to see what can what
and how to take advantage of these
there's additionally beyond the
bacterial systems I just mentioned
growing interest in developing simple
expensive inexpensive and high yielding
eukaryotic cell free translation systems
so my lab for example is developing some
systems in yeast and we've shown
improvements up to to about the tens of
micrograms per milliliter and are
starting to move beyond that and also
significant reductions in cost
thousandfold improvement over where we
initially started just a few years ago
some other application areas though that
I'd really like to delve into is this
idea that we'd like to extend the
central paradigm of biology to do
chemistry is about natural polymers so
so one of the exciting things you might
be able to do outside of the confines of
a cell is to be able to expand the
chemistry of life but this is also being
done in cells to be cleared but cell
free systems offer some particular
advantages for different unnatural amino
acids that might otherwise be difficult
to get across the cell membrane so what
you'd like to think about is to encode
some protein or a polymer in DNA allow
for the transcription of that into RNA
allow for the translation of that it's a
protein or polymer by the ribosome but
we now like to rather than use just the
simple 20 amino acids the biology has
provided us or or they're actually a few
more than that but the 20 canonical we
can then move to basically produce
polymers of those those adventure amino
acids polymers with a single unnatural
with multiple identical with multiple
distinct and all the state I think this
is a vision certainly put forward by a
variety of the field among others you
know Peter Schultz Jason chin a variety
of others have pushes but to achieve
this vision we need new tRNAs that can
be ameliorated with non-standard amino
acids and codons that could be assigned
to these amino acids and ribosomes that
allow for the formation of new polymers
and my lab is actually working on these
in the context of cell free systems and
really over the last decade or so
pioneering efforts have really
demonstrated that it's possible to
genetically encode more than 20 natural
amino acids and this is enabling some
exciting opportunities for genetic
isolation provide a safety of different
organisms and the production of
genetically encoded materials new
biological insights and even designer
protein therapeutics so for example to
come pre amber X also I know the company
suture biopharma is working in this
space among others the problem of course
with these types of systems is actually
at the moment they're not very efficient
so the state of the art for
site-specific non-standard amino acid
incorporation where basically what
you're doing is you're taking a tRNA and
you're recoding it in this case an Amber
tRNA to leverage and use a natural you
acid this gets charged by a natural
synthetase this is then charged tRNA is
transported to the ribosome by ef-tu
and this elongation factor to you
ultimately drives the synthesis into the
into the ribosome and competes against
this release factor so this is kind of
the state of the art how it's done and
amber stop codon suppression really uses
three stop codons more than more than
seventeen non-standard amino acids have
been incorporated to date but the
average that's incorporated is about one
to three non-standard amino acids per
protein applications however remains
severely restricted because low
efficiencies that the incorporating
these non-standard amino acids and so
what are the limitations so first of all
that the synthetases tend to have the
charges of natural acids tend to have
poor catalytic efficiency and and that
leads to sometimes inaccurate and
inefficient incorporation of these
non-standard amino acids for some
unnatural you know acids the binding of
this
transport protein elongation factor to
you is is a challenge and so you have to
actually evolve this element to the
translation apparatus and lastly for an
Amber suppression basically this amber
trna is competing with a release factor
that's endogenous of the cell this
causes it early termination and really
over the last couple of years this
problem has been mostly solved by a
variety of playing in their pioneering
efforts some shown here and others that
we have actually been been a part of so
in particular fair and Isaac's with
George Church at Yale University and
Harvard University of Ehrlich created
the first ever organism with a dedicated
xxi codon so they created a genomically
recode organism that basically lacks all
occurrences of the amber codon and also
is able to delete release factor one and
so the publications are shown here and
basically what we've been able to do is
that you can show is that you can use
these chassis organisms so in particular
these release factor one deletion
organisms to improve the synthesis of
fowling proteins containing
site-specific non-standard amino acids
so a publication for reference is shown
here by second home use one of my
postdocs was recently published in acs
synthetic biology the important thing is
what we did is we compared protein
synthesis with an unnatural amino acid
in a release factor one present strain
versus release factor one absent strain
and and critically what you observe this
is an autoradiogram what you observe is
the full-length protein of in this case
GFP protein that contains an amber at
position 132 and here's a truncated
protein and and when you lack basically
your have excuse me present release
factor one what you see is when you try
to produce the full-length protein
actually about eighty percent of your
product shows up here in the truncated
band whereas if you don't for example
add this impetus you don't get any of
the full-length product we see a
remarkable shift when you move to the
release factor one absence drain so in
this case a very little truncated
product most of the product is moved up
to this full-length band and that's very
exciting for us so you can see the
quantitation of those numbers here so
wild-type GFP in this case we we see the
improvement in the absence of release
factor one to this this
and so we're very excited about this and
I think that there are exciting
opportunities to improve these systems
so this is based in a strain called
rector team where 13 of the essential
genes and and some 7-8 essential genes
and some others have been recoded with
the sambar well my labs that done is
basically tried to design a better
catalyst the idea is this the cell
lysate is a catalyst and so you have a
genomic leary coded organism and what
we'd like to do is apply genome
engineering strategies to improve the
extract performance so so you imagine
that if you change the overall
composition of the catalyst or this
crude cell lysate you could change the
overall efficiency of the cell free
translation system and so rather than
using genetic engineering which is kind
of serial and has in some ways
inefficient modification of the DNA was
single to few genetic changes what we're
doing in my lab is applying genomic
engineering which allows for parallel
site-specific efficient modification of
the DNA and and using that to enhance
positive and remove negative effectors
so essentially what we're doing is we're
using this process called mage which was
developed at George church's laboratory
were then redesigning a liquid
nucleotides that basically each one of
these bands on this gel show that you
have a single protein that's been
knocked out of the genome both in
individual molecules as well as the
double here's a triple knockout this is
a quadruple knockout and what we then
did is we generated strains and e.coli
license from these strains to produce
products of interest and in the end the
key result is shown here so we have
non-standard amino acid incorporation in
these genomically recruited extracts
improves yields and achieves high
suppression efficiency so so what we
observe in in our work is that using a
genomically recoded organism we could
produce in this case that only has 13 of
the Umrah codons recoded we could
produce up to about 800 micrograms per
milliliter of sf' GFP with multiple
unnatural amino acids in it which really
I think compares very favorably to to
the state of the art so basically you
can see here as compared to a variety of
the other vivo reports that are out
there and just
standard batch reaction the in vitro
system using the same a national acid
has performed a little bit better and so
its summary from this half of the talk
what I'd like to just kind of show you
is that at least factor one deletion
strains can provide benefits for
incorporating multiple non-standard
amino acid sites specifically into the
same protein that you know McCleary
coded organisms can be used to improve
cell free performance and that looking
forward the development to release
doctor one deletion strains is a chassis
for cell-free translation will open new
avenues for using synthetic biology for
synthetic chemistry and what I'd like to
do at this stage is transition a little
bit to one of the other stories that I
mentioned we talked about and that is in
the context of synthetic ribosome so
really the extraordinary synthetic
capability of the ribosome has driven
extensive efforts to engineer the
translation apparatus so not only you
know and I show some statistics here
which is just that for example protein
elongation rates and bacteria proceed at
rates twenty mill acids per second
they're remarkably accurate and we do
have genetic and code ability and so if
you think broadly about the idea of
constructing synthetic ribosomes this
was a part of the translation apparatus
but this could afford new opportunities
for synthetic biology both had minimal
cell projects in potentially driving
virtual machines inside of organisms for
bogging all genetic control and
extending the central paradigm of
biology to the complete synthesis of a
biological polymers so the unfortunate
thing is that the requirement of
cellular viability really constrains the
mutations that can be made to the
ribosome so the natural ribosome must
decode every RNA of the cell therefore
mutations in the in the cell to the
ribosome are generally lethal it they
typically interfere with the endogenous
per diem
so this advance has been in part address
your something called the specialized
ribosome system but the issue is that
you don't have the ability to engineer
the large subunits of the ribosome and
so one of the goals of my lab has is to
construct synthetic ribosomes in vitro
and the ribosome is really this large
macromolecular machine which which
comprises of about 54 proteins or
twenty-one proteins in the small subunit
which is
here 33 proteins of a large subunit
which is shown here and we'd like to
learn how to construct these in vitro
and so to construct these in vitro we're
trying to use a molecular stepwise
approach whereby we both first get
reconstituted a natural ribosome of
completely in vivo purified parts we
then would have an in vitro synthesized
parts that we can basically combined
with the invivo purified parts and then
we have in this case the ultimate
construction of a synthetic ribosome so
so this of course has been done before
so in fact functional e.coli ribosomes
have been reconstituted from their
native parts their release of pioneering
works by new trout nomura that were
published in 1968 and canadian your
house at bern Anto which was published
in 1974 showing the ability to actually
reconstitute natural ribosomes this
reconstitution basically followed a kind
of in vitro non-physiological approach
whereby you could essentially take a
native large subunit break it into its
parts so it's 23 hours ribosomal RNA 5s
ribosomal RNA and the total protein of
the 50s subunit you then basically take
all these parts throw them into a test
tube and you can reconstitute this
central molecular machine of life which
in and of its own is is pretty
remarkable the challenge is that it
wasn't very physiological and the system
was fairly inefficient so in fact if you
look at major challenges in e.coli
drivers of construction ribosomes and
constitutions historically have been
non-physiological using these high salts
and high temperatures ribosome 3 cons of
you with in vitro transcribed 22 extra
23 guys driving similar day we're
essentially non-functional this is
unique to the coli system there are some
thermal files that have been used which
were successful and the coupling of
ribosomal RNA synthesis and assembly had
not yet been mimicked so one of these my
lab did in collaboration with George
Church at the Harvard Medical School is
to create a novel platform for the
construction of synthetic ribosomes
whereby basically you could synthesize
in vitro the parts of the ribosome
through transcription you then allow the
ribosome to assemble and you allow for
translation all in the same pot so
basically you have an integrated
synthesis assembly in translation system
that
a ribosome free crude extract of cells
and you have one bacterial page of t7
RNA polymerase that transcribes both the
ribosomal RNA and the message RNA of
this cell and so this system offers some
interesting advantages for Co activating
ribosomal RNA transcription and assembly
but it remained fairly inefficient so
basically you have all these parts that
you're adding into a test tube to allow
for these ribosomes to be self assembled
and to be able to basically carry out
their their activity of protein
synthesis but they're very inefficient
so this is an e coli ribosome and this
is the activity in the context of
producing a protein of these
synthetically constructed ribosomes so
they're actually about a little more
than ten thousand times less active and
purified E coli ribosome and so we
hypothesize that the activity of this
synthetic ribosome construction system
can be increased by several approaches
and several these are published now so
one is in the nucleic acids research
that my student Brian Fritz recently
published a Lou is published something
in ACS synthetic biology and really the
end result is that over the last four
years we've been able to increase
activity of the this synthetic ribosome
construction system about ten thousand
folds you see here basically activity is
a measure of the amount of protein we
can produce and you can see this large
increase over time and we're now almost
as good as if natural E coli ribosome in
our in our system we've also established
that this platform can make modified
ribosomes and that's very exciting
because this is important for exploring
ribosome mutants that potentially might
also be used for incorporating unnatural
amino acids like we talked about in the
earlier part of the talk so what we show
in this figure is luciferase production
on the y axis we use two different
ribosomal RNAs one that has a resistance
mutation a mutation that makes it
resistant to the antibiotic clindamycin
what we see is that in the presence of
clindamycin
only the the ribosomal RNA that is
resistant to that antibiotic actually
dysfunctional and so this was a very
exciting and important group of concept
and so what we've been able to show is
that ribosomal RNA synthesis assembly in
protein synthesis can be Co activated
without living cells and then ice at
this integrated synthesis assembly and
translation system
all the wrapping construction of
synthetic modified by bazooms in vitro
looking forward and we anticipate that
ISAT will aid in the variety of studies
the ribosome assembly and increasing
physiologically relevant conditions and
open new avenues for ribosome
engineering so I've tried to talk about
a couple of vignettes today one focused
on the ability to actually carry out
cell free protein synthesis and release
doctor one deficient strains that I've
shown that this allows us to really
incorporate on natural acids at a fairly
unprecedented scale at least of the same
type and at very high yields and then
went on to show that basically we could
carry out in vitro synthetic ribosome
construction in these systems cell free
biology ultimately I think is going to
offer some new frontiers for advanced
higher production systems both because
it reconceptualized this is the way we
engineer biological systems by truly
really decoupling this idea of catalyst
synthesis from catalyst utilization
there are definitely some key challenges
that the field is working on so scale up
efficiency moving beyond kind of e.coli
which is which is the Commons organism
that's used in the field but I think
we're gonna continue to see these
developments over the next few years so
there are some certainly some new
frontiers and cell-free
bio production systems as we talked
about designer ribosomes for the
production of new types of polymers and
materials wrap it on demand by
manufacturing for antibodies and
vaccines and sustainable synthesis of
quantity chemicals and materials I
didn't talk about but I think that the
future is certainly very bright so in
closing I would just like to acknowledge
a variety two people that did the work
so in particular the works that I showed
today ii hong worked on the released
after one mutation strains Brian Fritz
shown here and Allu shown here have done
a variety of the work and the in vitro
ribosome construction system as I
mentioned our lab has been sponsored by
a variety of organizations and it's
really important to have those
organizations supporting us such as for
example the Office of Naval Research
DARPA the Packard Foundation the Army
Research Office at the NSF which all
contributed in some way to some of the
research that you saw here today I'm
also very fortunate to have a variety of
collaborators that we work with
in a day to day basis so that's very
important
finally I'll close with a slide from the
lab showing us here at Chicago work
north of Chicago and Evanston this is
about the view from our lab sites and
I'd be happy to take any questions that
you have at this time please feel free
to type them in the box if they if there
are any that come to mind and I really
appreciate your time and attention today
all right so one of the questions that
just came in is the following and I'll
try to cover this briefly but basically
it's asked how durable are cellular
components after they're removed from
the cellular environment so once you
break the cell wall can't they be
continuously used as long as substrates
are provided or do they lose efficiency
very quickly this is a really important
question and I'm actually going to go
back to one slide to show the batch
reaction duration so so if you see here
on this excuse me I just want to be able
to get the pointer so if you see here
basically batch your action durations so
here we have this lysate of a cell that
is active in a in a batch reaction
producing protein for up to 12 hours
that gives some indication that for at
least 12 hours or so these proteins
without actually adding any extra
substrates or anything else can remain
active we've actually observed in some
cell free metabolic conversions the
ability to move beyond 24 hours and
still maintain activity so the longest
reports in the literature show that as
long as you're continuously feeding
substrates and continuously removing any
byproducts then you can actually get
these reactions to run for days it seems
that I think the longest the literature
is about five days Vincent Gallo who's
at the University of Minnesota is one of
the key people in the field who's been
able to show some of this work of course
Alexander Spearin was was the original
show the original work that that's
actually possible I think it's very
exciting
certainly that you can activate these
systems outside of the cell they remain
active in terms of the extent of - when
the system actually breaks down we don't
know the answer to that question so
thank you for that question I appreciate
it I'm available for other queries if
there are any
so we've actually had a another couple
questions roll in I'll try to answer at
least one of them here again so one of
the questions is do proteins fold
efficiently outside of the cellular
environment so if you take a protein and
you you know so let's say I want to
produce protein X how efficiently does
it fold so interestingly enough this is
one of the exciting opportunities of the
cell-free translation systems is their
proteins tend to fold fairly efficiently
and it's actually for two main reasons
so one of the main reasons is that the
so for example let's take a bacterial
cell pre translation system we produced
molecules anywhere from full-length
antibodies to tissue plasminogen
activator which is a molecule which is
allows blood clots and heart attack
victims to granulocyte
colony-stimulating factor which helps
kind of stimulate way blood cell
production to even you know single chain
antibodies so we can produce molecules
with complex dye folded complex
disulfide bond for disulfide bonds and
even things that need folding partners
one of the things that seems to be
important is that the cell-free
translation systems are an order of
magnitude slower in translation rate
than what occurs itself so in the
context of the bacterial cell protein
synthesis rates are on the order of
about 10 to 15 amino acids per second
whereas in the cell-free translation
system we tend to observe on the order
of one amino acid per second and what
that means is that ultimately the slower
translation rate tends to help proteins
fold a little bit more efficiently than
they would otherwise inside of a cell so
the second reason why folding is
oftentimes advantageous in these
cellular life states is actually because
of the dilution effect so the cellular
milieu is on the order of two to three
hundred grams per liter of protein
concentration whereas these cell free
lysate SAR on the order of ten to ten
grams per liter or so and so that
reduction of about twenty fold
ultimately means that as proteins are
being folded they have a lower chance to
actually aggregate so if you think of
protein folding is a unimolecular event
so protein comes off the ribosome
Folds protein aggregation is actually a
dual effect so basically you have two
proteins that come together to begin
aggregating so it's always a
second-order effect or greater and as
you think about that basically the the
magic rule in protein refolding or two
is to keep solutions dilute and so it
just happens to be that we we actually
benefit to produce proteins in their
active conformation by using a lower
concentration or actually the the
cellular concentration of just kind of
general proteins is lower so another
question that's popped in that we should
talk about and please feel free to keep
asking questions you know we'll see how
many we can get to is actually the
question of how how different is the
synthesis of therapeutics from chemicals
of in in in vitro so in the context of
cell free protein synthesis systems i
should add that basically the
state-of-the-art at the moment is we can
begin to produce complex therapeutics
such as you know full-length antibodies
but there is not yet for example a Food
and Drug Administration or an FDA
approved process for producing protein
therapeutics in vitro I think that's
going to change in the next few years
but essentially that process is is
producing a protein and so when you do
that what you need to add to the system
is a DNA molecule that encodes for let
me actually go back to the slides here
but basically you need to add a DNA
molecule that encodes for the protein of
interest you'd like to make and that
allows you to basically do that the
trick is with chemicals it's a little
different so if you want to think about
producing chemicals you're not actually
over expressing generally proteins of
that process at least in a crude extract
system in that case what you're actually
doing is you are simply trying to
provide the catalysts that allow for
conversion of let's say glucose to
whatever product you have an interest
and
pretty unlikely sin the context of
crewneck shark systems sin pen cos lab
at the eth is one of the more
predominant ones Jim Schwartz's lab at
Stanford has really shown some beautiful
work as well as this company green light
Biosciences in the context of in purely
in vitro system so all the systems that
I talked about today we recruit extract
systems there are a lot of works out
there with in the context of chemicals
and and most of those chemical systems
are actually done with purified in vitro
systems so there are actually commercial
processes with single purified enzymes
so glucose isomerase for example which
helps make fructose and others but
they're very few commercial examples of
multi-enzyme pathways but that is a very
active area of research and and i and
it'll be interesting and exciting to see
what what opportunities come about in
the future another question that's
popped up here is what kind of
challenges do you admission for the
scale-up of your celebre system so
really there are a couple the key thing
is the substrate cost so one of the
things that had always historically
limited cell-free translation systems
for example to small-scale were the
cause so if you look at this this figure
here where we basically have you know
small reaction scales the reaction
volume leader scales so we're down here
at the micro liter scale for such a long
time basically in this case what we
actually are observing is that these
these systems from once again these
systems are so small because of the the
dominant cost here really the energy
substrate so you would end up having for
example
boström priority as a secondary energy
step straight which is about 160 dollars
a gram and so you can compare that to
for example glucose which you could buy
from sigma for you know five cents a
gram or something and so you can see
that really the important element is
basically to feed a cell-free system the
same type of molecule you would feed a
cell that's one of the core constraints
the other thing is kind of just cofactor
and energy regeneration so turnover
numbers cells are very good at that so
how do we recapitulate those processes
the third really I would say in the
context of challenges for scale-up is
this idea that we'd like to we'd like to
keep the proteins active so there's not
really a way to regenerate a protein at
least in a continuous basis so I think
that there are some process engineering
objectives and opportunities a kind of
classical bioprocess engineering that
could be applied to these systems in the
future we could also begin because the
systems don't have walls you can begin
to open yourself to the decades of work
that's going on in reaction engineering
by for example heterologous catalysis by
kind of classic chemical engineering
methods and use standard kind of online
detection and control I think could be
applied to these systems so another
question that's that's come up is can
you comment on the prospects for using
celebre systems as prototyping
environment for developing pathways to
be scaled in cells so so this is a great
question and actually we're doing this
now in my lab and would be happy if you
reach out to me post this conversation
to talk a little bit more specifically
about that Jim and and and so but I
think that there are there's a
significant development right now both
using purified enzyme systems as well as
extracts to achieve that exact goal so
there are a couple implications and in
vitro purified systems which have just
shown the ability to prototype and
identify the right ratios of enzymes and
there are also some opportunities in
extracts but I think I think that's
definitely a direction that the field is
moving are there other questions that
people have I've gotten through the bulk
of the list here I'd be happy to to take
a few more
okay there don't seem to be any other
questions rolling in so I'll wait a few
more seconds here if you have something
that's burning otherwise for those of
you that tuned in it's actually a little
interesting to try to present this way
without actually being able to see the
audience but please do feel free to
email and follow up with any questions
that you may have to me I'm sure you can
find my email online mentioned that you
had seen this presentation and and I'd
be delighted to talk with you more fully
or in a different environment if you
would like to do so so with that thank
you I guess for all of your great
questions I hope everyone enjoy the
seminar and enjoy your day